est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire comment
votre vie a basculé un certain jour de
mars 1944 c'était même le 13 mars que
s'est-il passé ce jour là il ya on
s'était réfugié en zone libre et on
avait retrouvé une vie normale toute la
famille à agneaux et le 13 mars 44
je rentre pour déjeuner et la gestapo il
a je ne tiens pas qui a prononcé le mot
juif parce qu'il y avait devant celles
de la gestapo
mon père 61 ans lui on faire casquer mon
petit frère julie merck avait 12 ans et
demi et mon neveu qui avait 14 ans je ne
sais pas qui a prononcé le mot juif et
quand on était en zone est bon
actuellement on a dit à personne que
l'on était juif
on était orthodoxe mon nom de famille ni
ses chars casque c'est pas breton ne
s'est pas auvergnat donc d'origine russe
eh ben on peut être étranger sans être
juif et on était orthodoxe fallait pas
me demander ce que c'était que la
religion orthodoxe n'aurait pas su
l'expliquer mais on pensait que tout le
monde nous croyait en fin de compte
personne le groupe rejette toute une
famille qui vient se réfugier en zone
libre
ça sentait vraiment se cacher et 1
par contre cela lui a peut être pas plus
et on a été dénoncé donc ce jour là
j'arrive on faisait les marchés sur
avignon et le hasard a voulu que je
vienne déjeuner et c'est au moment où je
suis je veux que je rentre à la maison
peu la gestapo ya est devant nous il ya
mon père mon frère et mon neveu est
immédiatement vous êtes juif via vous
arrêter aux régimes non on n'est pas
juif
la démarcation à angoulême on était que
les femmes et
quand on l'a dit on n'est pas juif eh
ben on a montré les églises jour cet
effet soit disant baptisé première
communion donc ça a marché
moi je pense que ça va marcher mais non
ça n'a pas marché
il y avait trois personnes du sexe
masculin de vente où on était dénoncé la
gestapo est au courant de la
circoncision chez lui ils ont fait des
cultes et mon père mon frère et mon
neveu il n'ya pas sincères devant moi
c'est déjà pas mal
extrêmement et naturellement ils étaient
chacun si ils ont même fait même pas le
gars mais non ça doit rien dire ça ne
s'est pas 600 pas ne peut pas d'accord
on est dénoncée au maire d'arqués mais
en même temps car vous savez que vous
avez été des nausées mais ce que vous
savez par qui vous avez un dîner en
scène vous savez c'est ça qui est
terrible c'est qu'on accuse peut-être on
pense à des gens qui n'ont rien fait par
contre celui qui était peut-être votre
meilleur ami c'était cuit
vous n'avez jamais su ah non j'avais
cherché à recevoir
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas si nous
serons cherché à savoir parce que moi
comme je suis rentré j'ai pas du tout
passé à me venger mais on sait pas on
sait pas nous en interne et avignon vous
êtes internes et aux baumettes la drancy
dans la tristement célèbre camp de
drancy et ensuite direction l'est est ce
que quand vous voyez que vous prenez la
direction de l'ess vous avez une
quelconque idée du lieu où vous allez et
de ce qui vous attend
non personnellement moi je me savais
d'abord primo je ne savais pas qu'on
allait dans l'est parce que notre bague
on était à bagan aveugle il n'y avait
pas de sonner tout est ensuite quand on
était à drancy
moi je croyais ce que les nazis nous
racontait qu on allait dans un com
travaille et j'ai toujours cru que
j'allais la rencontre aveugle et il mon
père était certainement plus
intelligente mois mais jamais quand on
est à drancy
alors qu'ils avaient tout nuit
représentant de l'humanité vous avez des
vieillards des enfants des bébés
et des gens motivés je les voyais
cependant mais jamais j'ai eu l'idée de
dire il va pas pouvoir aller travailler
c'est pas vrai il ya quelque chose de
faux là dedans et puis mon père ne m'a
jamais dit mais ginette descend sur
terre regarde cette dame regarde ce bébé
ils n'ont pas arrêté pour aller
travailler
non moi je voyais et je croyais ce qu'on
disait on va dans un comm travail et il
n'avait pas peur et on glisse deux camps
de travail vous vous retrouvez et le
jour
vous êtes à auschwitz est également le
dernier jour vous avez vu votre père et
votre frère s'est il passé pour eux le
pire c'est que je me suis toujours
sentie responsable alors que c'est faux
mais bon c'est comme ça c'est que quand
on est descendu les wagons je me suis
fait traduire les ordres que peuvent
entendait et les autres c'était que les
personnes puissent en fatigue et les
personnes qui sont malades les personnes
qui ne veulent pas marcher
vous avez des camions à votre
disposition parce qu' il va y avoir un
moment traverser le champ pour rejoindre
le camp c'est pas où le train s'arrête
il faudra marcher un petit pull au m moi
j'entends sa venue à mon père et à mon
petit frère
mais prenez les camions vous serez pas
fatigué comme ça ils nous disaient qu'on
allait se retrouver
pourquoi mettre leur parole en doute et
m'ont écouté quand j'ai voulu leur dire
au bar un petit bisou comme ça il est
déjà parti mais ça ne me gênait pas
c'est ce que nous disaient mais vous
allez vous inquiétez pas vous inquiétez
pas vous avez tous se retrouver dans le
camp et vous ne les avez jamais revu non
et on vous explique en fait très tôt que
beaucoup de détenus sont gazés brûlé et
vous ne le croyez pas dans un premier
temps comment voulez vous croire ça mais
c'est pas possible puisque même
maintenant encore on en parle maintenant
si quand même et j'en commence à y
croire mais tout à fait au début comme
ceux qui sont rentrés ont dit qu'ils ont
brûlés mais non réussies ont raconté des
blagues 1
c'était pas possible mais c'était
comment voulez vous pensez que des êtres
humains
honteux revoyez des bébés des enfants
j'arrive à en commettre d'en avoir du
mal à penser à ça bien sûr mais
qu'est-ce qui vous dans cet enfer qu'est
ce qui vous choque le plus c'est en
arrivant à auschwitz je ne peux pas dire
ça m'a choqué j'avoue franchement il ya
tellement vous savez on a tellement été
en très peu de temps
des êtres humains qui deviennent de rien
du tout alors il ya tellement de choses
le raja la nudité ça pour moi ça a été
terrible d'être nu il y avait que des
femmes et à maîtriser même pas mais
c'était que des femmes et se trouvait
nulle part des personnes que vous ne
connaissez pas à notre époque c'était
pas comme maintenant
moi maintenant je fais cantine salle de
gym je me balade je suis apte oil salsa
ça ne me gêne pas du tout alors que à
l'époque même devant mes soeurs je me
mettais pas vu on était sig
on se déshabillait dans un endroit on se
couchait tous dans la même chambre
mais on était en pyjama gauche mise lui
sur les deux grilles on vous déshabille
pour vous raser pour vous tatouer une
impression d humanisation mais alors
c'est d'abord la nudité est affreuse
pour moi couteau moi les autres c'est
pas le tatouage le tattoo la gelée même
pas ressenti moi parce que j'étais moche
et ça c'était quelque chose d'affreux
alors quand on m'a tatouée comme ils ont
voulu frotter sur leur numéro
mais un numéro il encore le mien il est
beau hein je peux garder mais pour
certains c'est moi bien eh bien elle
frotte est maintenant sa part passé taxé
profond dans la chair moi je sais même
pas si ça m'a fait mal je ne sais même
pas si ça marche je n'y ai des tatoués
ghana oui parce que elle pensait que
c'était dans leur chair et que toute
leur vie elles auraient ce numéro dans
leur chair moi je n'ai même pas pensé à
ça j'étais nu vous rendez pompe nu
devant tout ça est alors après bon c'est
là le rasage je pourrais même dire
que quand on a été rasé vous savez quand
on est jeune on arriva même dans les
moments tragiques mais je reconnaissais
plus mes camarades je me souviens il y
avait une petite jeune fille qui
s'appelait marcel où l'homme dans l été
et rousse avec les cheveux tous ruinés
dans ce qu on la retrouve la trace est
complètement on l'a coupé les cheveux
mais c'était invisible même une mère
elle reconnaissait pas sa fixant cheveux
marceline loridan qui est morte
d'ailleurs récemment à chacune de vos
amis aussi vous vous demandez pourquoi
vous avez gardé ce tatouage
alors quand j'étais libéré s'était
attiré gym stats
la première chose que j'ai pensé comme
j'étais malade je me voyais à lui avoir
besoin d'une opération
et je me voyais demandé aux chirurgiens
pendant que je suis endormi enlevé mon
numéro et puis j'ai pas été opéré et
j'ai jamais eu le courage d'en lever
dalibard a chirurgien pour un paiement
numéro mais je peux vous dire que
pendant jeudi cinq ans à peut-être six
ans a peut être dix ans je ne m'en
souviens plus jamais jamais je le dis
mais mon bras l'été il faisait très
chaud
j'avais un petit pansement
j'allais à la piscine je me paie un
pansement on voyait pas mon numéro et
comme métier
j'avais appris hier par tout le temps
dehors quand j'ai été voir le médecin
qui me soigner quand je suis rentré il
m'a dit ne leva pas dans les bureaux
quand je trouve une place devant deux ça
sera mieux
et quand je suis ramené comme des bouts
mais seuls les deux j'ai dit le docteur
m'a dit ça j'ai une soeur qui avait
quitté son amoureux qu'elle avait à
hasnon il faisait les marchés à auber
mouillé et de l'allemand audi puisque
une fois devant 2 je prends ma place
un match retour m et voilà comment que
j'ai et je travaillais pendant les
années toujours couverts et puis un jour
une cliente en l'amenait à percy mon
numéro est anobli votre téléphone
et du coup ça m'a bas c'est le sam
ça faisait déjà longtemps de jeunes
moins de 21 comment l équipement de ce
qui s'est passé
moi je croyais tout le monde savait est
pour même maintenant mais on voit des
gens qui savent pas que le tatouage
c'est pas ça mais dans le temps les
bébés les enfants y voyait mon numéro
avec leurs petits doigts ça lui échapper
maintenant mes enfants mes s'habituer à
voir des dessins bombe
j'ai mis un numéro c'est pour vous
madame aujourd'hui le tatouage
aujourd'hui le tatouage représente pour
vous le symbole d'une femme qui a été
condamnée ou bien le symbole d'une femme
qui a survécu
quand je pars en numéro lui seul un
condamné non si les gens qui ont un
numéro
c'est tous des personnes vous savez il
ya qu à berck une autre aux comptes à
tous et pour vous aujourd'hui ça
représente quoi pour vous je sais pas ça
représente eux il est là il reste peut
pas dire que je suis toujours dans
l'école je mentirais et j'ai un
caractère qui fait que je suis assis je
viens lépi a pas de raison que ce papa
j'ai de la chance
donc ça ne représente rien j'ai pas
besoin de l'abarth de regarder le numéro
pour me rappeler que j'ai été déporté et
pour les gens qu'ils veuillent mon
numéro
certains se d'où peut-être le savent
mais beaucoup ça se passerait même
kolinka vous viviez comme aux autres
compagnons d'infortuné dans des
conditions terribles appel nourrit vous
y pensez voilà dormir dans des
conditions épouvantables mais est ce que
au milieu de cet enfer il vous arrivait
de vous projeter dans l'avenir c'est à
dire de penser un jour je ne serai plus
là un jour je fêterai les cinq ans de ma
libération et un jour peut-être les 76
ans de ma libération où vous vivez au
jour le jour sans espoir je ne sais pas
comment mes camarades
pensez ne pensez pas moi du jour où je
crois que toujours où je suis j'ai mis à
pied de berkane ô mon chien vous ne
travaillez plus est ce que c'est parce
que j'ai envoyé mon père et mon petit
frère dans les chambres à gaz et qu'ils
aient envoyé se faire assassiner que ça
m'a fait un choc psychologique ça fait
bien de dire ça j'irai voir un psy dirai
peut-être ça ici je crois que je j'ai
été tout de suite plus rien alors mes
camarades j'avoue franchement j'ai
jamais posé la question
les camarades un pouvoir elle pas ce
qu'il en était mais pour moi c'était
comme ça j'ai du jour je crois que du
jour où j'ai mis un pedobear que nos mon
cerveau ne savait plus pensé et je
reviens quelques secondes en arrière
vous avez prononcé une phrase terrible
avait dit j'ai envoyé mon père et mon
frère c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est faux
des années plus tard des dizaines
d'années plus tard vous avez encore
cette culpabilité ont toujours je crois
que j'aimerais c'est moi qui aurais dit
de monter alors que en réalité
de toute façon on les aurait obligées
sûr puisque pour l'une à j moins de 15
ans on ne peut pas travailler
donc on va pas nous nourrir et plus de
45 ans pour les femmes et est
cinquantaine pour les hommes ne peuvent
pas travailler donc on veut bien ouvrir
à conditions sabeg
et voilà alors ça se paie quand on
rentrait dans le camp et une faille dans
le temps alors c'était l'apparence alors
en 45 30 juin vous êtes rapatriés depuis
un autre camp jusqu'à lyon et ensuite
paris et comment se passent les
retrouvailles avec le reste de votre
famille votre mère et les soeurs qui
n'avait pas été déporté pour moi pour
moi du fait qu'on avait été dénoncé
toute la famille avaient été arrêtés
seulement bien que nos obsessivement
grand plus grand même que je ne pensais
eh bien
on pouvait avoir son père les hommes
étaient dans un camp les femmes dans un
autre on ne pouvait pas se voir mais par
contre quand on était en transe
j'avais pu avoir ma mère dans un coin de
berck et nos masseurs dans un autre coin
de berkine haut et on n'aurait pas si
d'accord rayon des morceaux donc pour
moi tout le monde a été arrêté mon père
mon frère je n'étais pas ces partis en
fumée et donc quand j'étais rapatriés je
pensais les retrouver et vous pas lui a
retrouvé sa je ne savais pas et quand on
a été rapatriée je me suis retrouvé
aliot dans un centre d'accueil et c'est
là que j'ai appris
quelqu'un qui nous montrait des photos
est ce que vous l'avez comme us que
l'esprit ce qu'elle s'arrête devant moi
elle me regarde
elle me reconnais comme une fille sharks
à skis ben oui je me rappelle encore de
mon nom et elle m'a appris que ma mère
et mes soeurs n'avaient pas été déportés
et même que j'avais récupéré
l'appartement que nous avions à paris
parce que en principe quand un jeune
s'était arrêté son appartement était
vidé et puis le propriétaire et ben le
loup et actu rouler et on a eu la shdm
et soeurs et ma mère ont eu la chance de
notre appartement a été occupé par des
collaborateurs
j'en avais c'est un bureau d'embauché
pour envoyer les jeunes travailler comme
st lô
donc je sais pas si c'est ma soeur qui
ont dénoncé je ne sais pas si la
concierge vous allez lancer en tous les
cas ils ont été en prison et puis ma
mère a pu récupérer l'appartement avec
mes soeurs donc quand à lyon cette dame
se s'arrête devant moi me reconnais je
sais pas qui étaient ces dames
moi j'ai cru que c'était quelqu'un de la
famille e et puis que je la reverrai
après enfin deux potes je n'ai jamais je
n'ai jamais revu personne ne m'a dit
c'est moi qui t'ai dit je sais pas
quand je suis arrivé donc de long à
paris moi je voulais aller chez moi mais
non il fallait passer par l'hôtel
lutetia où il y avait un centre très
important un centre d'accueil et là tous
les prisonniers d'air et tous les
déportés en principe devait passer par
là pour redire qu'ils étaient pas s'il y
aurait pu y avoir des collaborateurs qui
se glisse parmi nous d'énergie se pose
parmi nous donc on répondait à des
questions dans tous les bureaux c'était
les mêmes questions pub j'ai comparé
réponse et c'est là que je croyais
retrouver j'avais prévu à lyon que
j'étais vivante
donc je pensais que mes soeurs seraient
là l hôtel lutetia comme lvt pas je suis
rentré par mes propres moyens il y avait
des photos muscles et je me suis
retrouvé à la maison
à paris me souviens que la foncière
jelade cross dans la rue c'est elle dans
la course était la même conscience
qu'ils avaient il ya trois ans elle me
prend pour mon petit frère
j'ai été rasés j'avais pas de cheveux
j'étais habillé en tenue d'hôpital donc
pantalon et puis j'avais sur le dos une
veste allemande je sais pas qui veulent
la nuit peut-être à urgences elle même
comme un cas j'ajoute un oui par les
indiens d'amérique
on nous écoute a évidemment avec passion
mais j'ajoute un détail pour constitue
bien votre calvaire ou peser 26 kg en
revenant en ai jamais corps étaient
nourris à theresienstadt est a lyon je
peux dire que mon poids le poids de mise
au jeu comme ça doit être dans les 24 25
kg qu'est ce qui nous a fait tenir
madame je sais pas la chance moi je peux
dire que la chance là qu'il me dise la
volonté le courage non se pavanent je
n'étais pas capable d'avoir de la
volonté je n'étais pas capable de battre
du courage c'était la chance
d'être là au bon moment et ma chance qui
était une malchance au départ mais la
chance c'est que en novembre
alors j'ai même appris hier que c'était
en octobre en octobre 44
il y à un premier départ de berck
hainaut et je suis je suis à ce jour là
donc je vais partir de dire qu'une eau
mais entre moi j'ai pas fait la marche
de la mort donc c'est en train que je
suis parti pour arriver à verdun baie
james et bergues and then c'est plus un
conte d'extermination c'est un camp de
concentration
alors on y meurt mais dans notre
proprement et madame collin cas on en
arrive à un point commun de beaucoup de
déportés c'est que pendant très très
longtemps
comme beaucoup de compagnons d'infortuné
vous ne parlez pas de ce qui est arrivé
vous ne parlez pas de cette captivité
vous ne parlez pas de tout ce que vous
avez subi
pourquoi ce silence alors il y en a qui
disent parce qu'on ne serait pas cru moi
c'est pas le cas
moi je vais pas vous crois que je crois
que beaucoup de personnes ne croyaient
pas c'est assez difficile à ces mêmes
maintenant quand on parle si j'arrive
même à dire mais c'est pas possible pas
pu faire tout ça donc s'il est bien
pensée pour pape à ce jeu j'étais la
seule de toute la famille oncles neveux
cousins tous la seule à être rentrés et
puis je vais raconter tout ce que je
supportais et vécu mais les autres s'ils
ne sont pas là comment que attend mon
père et mon frère je sais qu'ils ont été
gazés mais le jeu maintenant plus je ne
sais pas comment j'ai vu des camarades
mourir s'il le couple le capot j'ai vu
des camarades mourir de maladies de soin
d'eux et bien comment sont mortes et moi
je vais raconter tout ce que les unit
est comme ça j'ai ma famille va se
demander comment qu'ils sont morts
comment comment comment comment alors
moi je préférais pas en parler c'est
encore une forme de culpabilité je vais
pas chercher temps
ça je fais les choses sont claires le
pourquoi de choses ça a été comme ça moi
je voulais pas et puis alors ce que je
voulais surtout pas c'était embêter les
gens a raconté toujours mon histoire
moi j'ai ma mère je marquais beaucoup
parce que à côté on habitait dans le
quartier de l'hôtel de ville
et c'était le marais mais c'est pay pal
mal à l'époque un élu ma mère toutes les
vitres de l'appartement ont été cassées
quand il ya eu la bombe
c'était la grosse bertha salon en a
entendu parler et qui elle me casser les
pieds avec sa grosse bertha et j'ai dit
ben moi je parlerais pas qu'on ne soit
jamais très pâle et jean adiaf j'ai eu
si je me suis j'ai fait ça non mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que les épreuves
étaient tellement terrible que même les
victimes éprouvent un sentiment de
culpabilité c'est bien c'est rare et non
non elle aura en tout cas m'a
personnellement je ne lui en ont pas du
tout alors absolument pas j'ai jamais eu
autant de non non pas du tout je me sens
pas du tout pas bleus d'être entré amado
a bien parce qu'il ya eu des cas comme
ça des gens qui se sentent si jamais
j'ai jamais interrogé mes camarades de
déportation pour ce qu'ils ont fait ce
qu'elles n'ont pas fait ce qu'elles ont
dit ou pas dit en tous les cas
personnellement moi je n'ai jamais
jamais eu un sentiment de culpabilité
ah ben non il n'y a pas de raison
pourquoi pare-feu cd mais un jour vous
rompez le silence pourquoi et dans
quelles circonstances ce qui s'est passé
mais là encore ça a été un hasard
je fais partie d'une association qui
s'appelle une et à l'union des déportés
d'auschwitz
il amenait toujours le président de
cette association a met toujours
quelques déportés c'était toujours les
mêmes pour accompagner les groupes
d'élèves qui en est à berck hainaut et
parmi ces étaient quatre et parmi ces
4 y en a une qui tend du malade et il
était embêté il je commence à se
raconter cette association parce que
sinon moi je travaillais et les
associations ce samedi dimanche prix
fort leur réunion moi je travaillais
c'était mes meilleurs jours je n'ai pas
quitté le travail pourra lui c'était à
mon compte je travaillais pas il n'y
avait pas d'argent qui entre donc je ne
fréquentais pas et puis je me suis
retrouvé à la retraite le temps tu m'emm
arrêté devant jeffrey comptait pas les
déportés lui a été prisonnier de guerre
mais j'allais pas l'embêter le traîner
avec moi
donc on a été ensemble tout le temps et
nous quand j'étais veulent là je me suis
je me suis mise à fréquenter mon
association
et puis un jour le président me demander
de remplacer quelqu'un j'ai pas voulu au
départ parce que j'avais pas besoin
d'aller là bas pour me souvenir
j'avais qu'à fermer les jeux d'été et il
était embêté ça m'aurait rendu service à
lola mais bon karma perdu et puis j'ai
accepté et puis j'ai jamais à regretter
parce que de plus ici régulièrement mais
la preuve avant d'y arriver
comme j'ai pas le caractère à me
tracasse yade avant ce qu'est ce que ça
va faire qu'est-ce que je vais me dire
qu'est ce qu'un test mais quand je suis
arrivé à dire que l'eau ce n'est pas
pire que çà mais tout est propre pour
moi quand j'accompagne un groupe avec
moi jordi mais non on fermait les yeux
c'est pas ça c'est pas ça certaines
autres bacs technos et la salle tel
c'est l'odeur c'est ça grouille de monde
non c'est un décor bien canaux non vous
n'avez pas n'avait pas réussi totalement
à transmettre l'enfer que c'était ça
parce que c'est peut-être aussi voilà
c'est peut-être impossible la
transparence il n'y a pas de mot avec la
langue française à l'irish à moi je dis
c'est un exemple on nous battait que ce
que ça qu'est ce que vous voyez vous
même magie quand on nous battait je vois
la personne par terre
r auprès de celui qui l'a battue et elle
continua à la battre je sais que tous
les côtés mais ça fait rien on continue
à l'abattre et puis après on va la
remettre debout pour qu'elles prennent
le travail
moi si ça continue on nous battait alors
que vous sujet on vous battez vous voyez
votre maman cloud angie votre pape
actuel
et puis c'est tout ça vous a lieu non il
n'y a pas de mots